A Few Good Men okay so
hard
well there's a couple of plent of things
one I had to audition for A Few Good Men
the only thing is is I was about seven
and a half months pregnant and so I had
to go waddling in Tom Cruz was mortified
but what I'll say the fly in thewall
moment in the big courtroom scenes when
Jack Nicholson is up on the stand they
were shooting the other dire
all day and here I'm watching this you
know iconic actor this actor that you
know I've grown up with that I have such
respect for do off camera at Full Steam
all day long it was something that just
moved me and really stayed with me on
the importance of of how we show up for
each other that is so amazing and it is
a good life lesson and a good example